(mellow music)
- Welcome to the Think Marketing Show,
the number one podcast
for growing and scaling
your business with online video.
I'm Heather Torres.
- And I'm Sean Cannell
and we're from Think Media and if this is
your first time listening, welcome.
This show is dedicated to helping you
learn how to get your content noticed
and the latest money-making strategies
working right now online.
So, whether you wanna
grow your YouTube channel
or maximize online video across
social media, this is for you.
We're answering some of
the biggest questions
we get in the community, in
the Think Media community,
and this one's comin' at you, Sean:
how do you get your first 100 subscribers?
100's a big deal and most
people think it needs to be
a million subscribers, but
that first 100 is critical.
- It is and, you know, some
people get there pretty quick
and some people, it feels like
it takes awhile to get there.
I think the first thing is you wanna
be patient with your own journey.
We're all starting, you
know, some people have
social media followings
pre-existing to YouTube,
so they can say, "Hey, I
started a YouTube channel,"
or send an email to their
list and grow their channel,
some people have to
really bootstrap from zero
with no connections, no social media.
So, it kinda depends on
where you're starting,
but I think the biggest thing is
there's really two different ways to start
and I hear, like, it's almost like
there's disagreement on this.
I think you really just
have to have self awareness.
One of the ways to start is actually to
just experiment and have fun,
to not feel the pressure of niching down,
of having a niche, because
that can be limiting
or on the other hand, though,
is to actually pick a niche.
That's the best way to start
but if you don't have clarity yet,
then it can be limiting
and you can overthink it.
And so, I don't know what
you think about that.
- Yeah, I think when I first
started my homeschool channel,
we had a discussion and it was like,
"Whatta you wanna start
your channel about?"
And that was a hobby that I had,
but I didn't know how to make videos,
so my experimenting wasn't necessarily
just about the content, it was about
understanding how to create videos.
So, my experience has
been getting to over 100
and over 1,000, over
15,000 with having a niche,
but my experimenting has been in
the content creation part of it.
- Sure.
- What about you?
- Well, you already knew your passion,
you already knew that you
had some experience there,
you'd read the books, it
was something you could
help people with, you had
people asking you about that.
But I know a lotta people
watching are maybe like,
"I don't have even, I don't,
"I don't, is homeschool my thing?"
And in that case, I actually,
even though I'm the guy
who's like, "Start with
clarity, start with a niche,"
I didn't start that way.
Like, on my channel, Sean Cannell,
and you can see the entire
history of these videos.
In fact, my story goes back to 2003.
I started shooting video of my church.
So, I got to do weekly video announcements
and learn video production that way.
Then, though, in 2000,
around 10, I wanted to
start a YouTube channel, but
I was all over the place.
I mean, I did an Amazing Spiderman review
and then a how to cook baked
salmon in a tin foil boat
and then I did vlogs with my
wife for about 50 days straight
and then I did just random videos of
traveling and of specific
reviews of, like,
the Palm Springs Aerial Tour.
And I was even learning a
little bit about search.
Like, Las Vegas horseback riding.
But it was just all kinds of random stuff.
Here's the thing: I did not have a niche,
I didn't have a niche, but I was getting
critical skills of the YouTube landscape,
of creating content on YouTube,
I was basically strengthening
my YouTube muscles.
So, I would argue that if it wasn't for
all that experimenting on
my Sean Cannell channel
that, like, Think Media
and Video Influencers
wouldn't be what they are today.
So, it basically comes down to this:
if you don't have clarity, just start.
Like, punch fear in the face,
punch perfectionism in the face,
and press record and just
start posting videos.
The thing is, that channel might not
even be the channel that succeeds.
Like, Sean Cannell eventually,
I think, will be something,
but it's just sitting
there while we're over here
on Think Marketing and have Think Media
and I'm doing Video
Influencers with Benji.
So, that was a learning
YouTube channel that led to
my successful YouTube channels
that I have over here.
On the flip side, maybe
you are already passionate
about running and so, you love
running, you do marathons,
you do half-marathons, you
own 50 pairs of running shoes,
you're obsessed with all of
the different running practices
and you're like, "What do I
start a YouTube channel about?"
Maybe running.
- Yeah.
- And that is an amazing
niche to blow up on.
People review shoes, they
look for the reviews of shoes.
I'm an aspiring runner.
So I just have done two
half-marathons, so I wanna learn.
I've been watching all these shoe reviews,
I'm subscribing to different people.
And I'm finding them why?
Because I also have a
similar specific passion.
So, don't judge yourself either way.
Either go variety or pick a
niche, but just get started.
- In celebration of the launch
of this brand new podcast,
we're giving away two tickets
to our annual conference,
Grow With Video Live, a $1,500 value.
- All you have to do enter
is make sure you subscribe,
leave us a review on Apple Podcast,
and then take a screenshot
of your review and go to
thinkmarketingshow.com for
the rest of the details.
- Yeah, I think, you know, it is also:
what's the end result
that you want to happen?
And there's so many paths up the mountain,
right?
- Yeah, absolutely.
That if you were to ever think that
there is only one right way to get there.
It's kinda like starting businesses.
I heard one of the sharks
from Shark Tank say,
"In your 20s and your 30s,"
and it doesn't matter what age you are,
it just means when you start getting into
that kind of entrepreneurial,
experimental, creative phase.
All the successful business
owners usually have had
one, two, three failed businesses
before they got to the successful one.
And so, he was saying,
"In your 20s and 30s,
"just do as much business
experimenting as you can
"until you kinda figure out a
little bit of self awareness,
"a little bit about what
works for you, a little about
"what has momentum, and
then go deeper on that."
I feel like YouTube's the
same, that's been my journey.
I mean, I got my Clearvision channel,
Think International channel,
my personal channel, my church's channel.
I had four channels that
I had been working on
before I got my breakout channels
that I'm kind of known for today.
That's a lot of experimenting.
I think we need to have more
permission to experiment more
and kind of judge ourselves less.
- Yeah, and getting to
that first 100 subscribers,
that's a milestone and I think sometimes
we don't think about, like,
during the experimenting phase
and getting into it,
that that is something
to be proud of, but I think it rocks.
I think it's awesome to get
to your first 100 subscribers
'cause you learned so
much on that journey.
- It's incredible.
I mean, think about, my
background's the church world
and I've been in ministry
for a lotta years
before kind of going into
what we'd call the marketplace
or, you know, kinda entrepreneurship.
And the average church in
America is under 80 people.
Which, that's incredible.
We're talking about, like,
an incredible community
where a pastor is
helping people, you know,
get through the challenges of life
and have a better relationship
with God and, you know,
overcome all types of different things,
And they're in this
community serving 80 people,
we're talking about 100
subscribers, you know what I mean?
That, like, no matter where
you are, no matter, you know,
I'm a college dropout, small town kid,
didn't come from, like, a
big city, didn't come from,
you know, all these connections
or all these types of things.
And you could just start
shooting videos in your bedroom
and get to a hundred subscribers?
You have a larger congregation
than, like, most churches in America,
if you will, if you
kinda use that analogy.
So no, you really have to, for sure,
don't compare yourself to
what somebody else is doin',
don't worry about the person who,
by the way, has been puttin' in the work
and has been on the platform for 10 years.
You're just getting started
and really celebrate the
subscribers you do have
rather than really worrying
about what you don't have yet.
- Thanks for checkin' out this episode.
We hope you got a ton of value.
And, if you haven't already,
subscribe here to the Think Marketing Show
wherever you're watching or listening.
- And hey, it would mean the world to us
if you would rate and review
this show on Apple Podcast.
- As we grow this movement of
purpose-driven content creators,
we encourage you to
share it with a friend.
And we'll see you in the next episode.
(mellow music)